und damit einen schönen guten morgen und
willkommen hierbei greifen wir begrüßen
im studio unsere kollegin nina schenk
und nena hat uns ihre aufreger die
geschichten die sie berühren die sie
wütend machen die sie nur noch mit dem
kopf schütteln lassen heute morgen
mitgebracht guten morgen vertrieb sehr
guten morgen keil stellen dass ich bei
euch sein darf ihr patricia es gab so
viel da muss ich mich wirklich
entscheiden aber ich möchte mal mit dem
ersten thema beginnen und zwar gibt es
die wissenssendung quark sie läuft im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk beim wdr
und die zeigte auf wie politik
funktioniert die zeitgeschehen
funktioniert evidenzbasiert wie sie
sagen ja ich habe heute morgen mal
angeschaut wie sie die klima programme
der parteien bewerten
evidenzbasiert würde ich erst mal schon
mal sagen nein sie haben eine
aufstellung gemacht es gibt ein video
das dürfen wir aus lizenzgründen leider
nicht zeigen ist in probier's mal nach
zu machen also das steht eine frau und
geht durch das sehen wir die frau jetzt
auch genau und da sehen wir genauso und
dann erzählt sie was die parteien
eigentlich wie sie das klima retten
wollen die sich als pariser klima
abkommen halten
co2-emission so und auf einmal macht sie
auf platz eins fdp dann sagt sie aber
die fdp ist nicht auf platz eins weil
das ist überhaupt nicht konkret also was
die form das machen sie ja gar nicht das
funktioniert nicht sie hat genau gesagt
dass auch nationale klimaziele hat auch
abgelehnt werden von der fdp die
orientieren sich nämlich steht auch bei
quarks auf der website stattdessen einen
vorgaben der eu die für 15 grad nicht
ausreichen ihre konkreten pläne seien
nicht realistisch da muss man sich jetzt
mal ganz ehrlich fragen also die fdp
landet bei dieser wissenschaftlichen
analyse des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks auf 1 dann gefällt dem
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk dieser
dame aber nicht dass die fdp auf 1 ist
und damit gleich nein die klimaziele
sind überhaupt nicht konkret
betriebsjahr die sind jetzt auf dem
vorletzten platz die landen nämlich dann
kurz vor der afd nur noch eine sache so
ein ordnung weil erstens finde ich es
furchtbar wenn müsste da übrigens
kommentar stehen das ist ja keine
analyse wenn man die regionale
entwicklung silwan empfehlung und
solange es ihnen dann nicht passt ja die
haben eigentlich so lange gemacht bis es
ihnen gepasst hat diese wahlempfehlung
dieser analyse und was mich ganz ganz
stark stört und es stört mich eigentlich
generell bei der klima berichterstattung
des öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks ist
diese panikmache es gibt ja wir reden
immer nur verzicht wir reden immer nur
auf über den verzicht der co2 emissionen
auch wieder bei dem beitrag aber es gibt
drei wege und ich ich muss leider sagen
ich glaube die dame hat auch die
technologieoffenheit der fdp nicht
begriffen weil über technologien zu
reden ist übrigens auch schwieriger als
zu sagen verzichtet wir müssen co2
emissionen einsparen das versteht ja
jeder aber wenn wir zum beispiel mit
director catcher technology reden das
versteht auch nicht jeder da muss man
sich mühe geben das zu erklären und
deswegen möchte ich die zeit hier nutzen
dafür zu werben drei maßnahmen die wir
haben um den klimawandel zu bekämpfen
maßnahme eins ist natürlich der verzicht
die reduktion der co2 emissionen
die zweite maßnahme ist sich auch den
wärmeren klima temperaturen anzupassen
und die dritte maßnahme ist
technologieoffenheit und technologien zu
benutzen und mir das heute furchtbar
aufgeregt das war wieder diese weltsicht
die fdp
ich wahrscheinlich war alles überhaupt
jegliche wahlomat der an dieser stelle
zumindest mal der klimapolitik die fdp
ausspuckte wo man da sagt was nicht sein
kann was nicht sein darf viele von uns
kennen das ja wenn sie in wahl o maten
macht übrigens heute vormittag war hatte
ergebnis dann macht man schnell noch mal
gut also jetzt eine klima klimaschutz
lehrstunde noch mal bekommen alle
aufgepasst aber das war nicht das
einzige was sich oft gering nein obwohl
das war schon ein guter start in den
wagen ein erwarten ist weiter im rennen
dann gibt es natürlich das zweite thema
da sind natürlich von frau berbalk also
es ist ja bekannt dass ich kein großer
fan von frau berbalk bin aber ich bin
immer wieder erstaunt was noch so kommt
heute ist es natürlich in baden
württemberg wurde jetzt die plattform
eingeführt wo man anonym denunzieren
kann und zwar wegen steuerbetrug also
man kann jetzt wenn man zum beispiel
seien nachbarn sieht im garten läuft
jemand rum mit dem spaten und dann zieht
man mal eben schnell auf der couch und
denkt sich vielleicht ist übrigens nur
der opa aber das ist ja völlig egal sind
also die plattform und meldet dass
anonym und frau berbalk heißt diese
plattform für gut weil sie kann sich
auch vorstellen dass bundesweit
einzuführen dann hätten wir also
bundesweit hätten wir also eine reine
eigentlich so was ich finde es ist wie
so eine straßen plattform wo wir uns
gegenseitig denunzieren sollen und ich
finde wir sind leere cola schon so weit
auseinandergedriftet die gesellschaft
ist schon überreizt wir haben jetzt
schon probleme warum jetzt auch noch
steuern anzeigen anonym schwarzarbeit
ist es wichtig gegen schwarzarbeit
vorzugehen aber es kann doch nicht sein
dass wir irgendwann uns alle gegenseitig
überprüfen und uns anonym melden vor
allem ist braucht auch so eine plattform
gar nicht weil es gibt ja jetzt schon
die möglichkeit beim finanzamt
steuerbetrug zu melden es gibt zum
beispiel in bayern beim finanzamt da
steht auch auf der webseite können man
kann man auch anonym melden und dann ist
die frage damit beantwortet ja das
können sie aber hinweise mit namen geht
man natürlich stärker nach bei
rückfragen erlaubt sind und das ist doch
einfach der punkt es geht mir vor allem
um diese anonymität wollen wir in einem
land leben wo wir uns alle anonym
gegenseitig denunzieren und wenn man was
gegen jemand anderen sagt sollte man
sich da nicht mit seinen namen
hinstellen und sollte nicht vor einem
gast in zukünftige bundeskanzlerin auf
verlangen also wenn ich jetzt sagen
würde betrieb sehr da ist irgendwas
komisch bei dem ich mich doch mit meinem
namen hinstellen ich wähle verein hoffen
und das wirklich kommunikation dass du
einfach erstmal mich ansprechen würde
ist bevor du irgendwie selbst mit namen
eine e mail schreiben würde ich bin
großer bedeutung denn direkt also und
hat viele herzliche grüße an dieser
stelle danke für deine hilfe und auch
ans finanzamt vielen dank dass wir mal
haben sie dies aber
er hat sich damit erledigt vertrieb sein
sie sind mit dem rhein an dieser stelle
soll es für petzold thema klare haltung
jener wir werden das gleiche prallen
immer meinungen aufeinander vertiefen
gleich wird cem özdemir zu gast sein
interessant aus baden württemberg der
finanzminister daniel baier ist hat
genau das vor in baden württemberg jetzt
gestützt von der grünen-spitze das aber
nicht genug aufregung an diesem
donnerstagmorgen nina was noch was hast
du noch in der tasche es gibt da ein
drittes thema ich will jetzt hier nicht
bei die aufreger nena halfen menschen
rächen ich würde jetzt schon bezeichnet
in der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung als dauer empörte
redakteurin dementsprechend war nicht
mein beruf ist heute morgen noch mal
alle ehre nein ich hat auch eine sache
sehr nicht aufgeregt sondern er gesagt
entsetzt und zwar sebastian kurz im
interview mit dirk gesagt dass er keine
flüchtlinge aufnehmen wird in österreich
das war für mich nicht nur unseriös
sondern auch inhuman aber vor allem war
es für mich auch einfach eine lüge an
den menschen auch seines landes weil
faktisch ist es so österreich wird
natürlich flüchtlinge aufnehmen und ich
möchte da gar nicht mit der moralkeule
kommen und jetzt die herzergreifenden
schicksale auf 10 von verfolgten
journalistin von verfolgten bloggerin
sondern ich will einfach mal bei den
fakten bleiben es wird nicht möglich
sein dass österreich niemanden aufnimmt
sonst würden sie sich komplett gegen den
europäischen vertikalen und gegen das
politische asyl stellen weil sobald
jemand es schafft von afghanistan dann
sollte er schafft nach österreich zu
gelangen dann wird selbstverständlich
wenn die kriterien für politisches asyl
erfüllt sind würde es auch gegeben
werden es ging finde ich dass sebastian
kurz mit seiner rhetorik erstmal sein
volk belogen hat weil er da eigentlich
gezeigt hat wir nehmen kein auf aber vor
allem ist es für mich komplett unseriös
und befürworter sagen ja er hätte sich
damit in eine starke
verhandlungsposition begeben bei damit
natürlich gesagt wird ich nehme kein auf
also stehe ich gut da in europa wenn es
um verhandlung geht wie viel ich nehmen
muss ich würde sagen die pr aktion ist
gänzlich schief gelaufen und es gibt für
mich keinen einzigen grund so zu
urteilen und ich bin dankbar dass wir in
deutschland keinen kanzler kurz haben
[Musik]